the iPhone 15 Pro Max has been out for
about 3 months and this past weekend I
finally realized that it was a mistake
to buy myself a pro camera namely the
$3,000 Sony A7 r4a because we just got
back from our trip to New York where we
spent hours walking around different
districts and even up in the tallest
building in the nation taking photos
with both the iPhone and this Pro camera
for our massive blind comparison and
I've learned that the I iPhone 15 Pro
Max is the first iPhone that's a better
camera for five different reasons the
first and main reason is that it
actually one in our blind camera
comparison video which by the way I'll
put in the end screen at the end of this
video so you can check it out I
literally carried the pro camera around
New York City for 3 Days taking a
variety of photos in the daylight Sunset
lighting indoor lighting nighttime and
with bright boka lights in the
background just to make sure we covered
all bases and even though the sensors on
the iPhone are significantly smaller
than the ones on the Pro Camera which
has a fullframe sensor Max and Ben both
chose around 5 to six more iPhone photos
than Pro camera photos out of a total of
35 and the crazy thing is that I used
the most basic HF photo mode which
barely uses any storage compared to
edited Raw photos on the Pro Camera
which have to save a ton of data in
order to give you the most flexibility
during editing for example with this set
of photos of the cybertruck that we got
to check out in the famous meat packing
District the iPhone's photo was 1.7
megapixels compared to
61.8 on the a7r 4 a mass of 36 times
larger and guess what the iPhone still
won because of the insanely good photo
stacking AI processing with smart HDR 5
but now getting into the second reason
why the iPhone is a better camera it's
the price PR the 15 Pro Max is only
$1,200 and it does a whole lot more than
just take photos it's basically your
connection to the world your family your
friends and to many apps games tech
devices and so much more now my Sony A7
R4 retails at $33,000 brand new but
that's just the camera body alone not
including the lens so because of that I
bought myself a budget lens Sony's 50 mm
f1.8 portrait lens which is only 200
bucks on Amazon but unfortunately that
simply doesn't compare to the iPhone
which is able to take photos at a
variety of different Zoom lengths
ranging from the ultrawide 12 mm camera
the main 1X camera which is 24 mm the
excellent new 2x Zoom mode which is 48
mm and the brand new 120 mm 5x camera
not even talking about the selfie camera
as well so because of that I had to
borrow this lens from her office which
is the Sony 24 to 70 mm GM lens which
costs
$2300 by itself being by far the best
fit that we have in order to match the
camera varieties of the iPhone but that
still wasn't enough because the iPhone
has the ultra wide which I didn't want
to get another lens to Lug around New
York for the Pro Camera and the iPhone
also has the 5x 120 mm camera so I
basically had to take photos at 70 mm
with the pro camera and crop in to
achieve the same level of zoom and to
think that you get a total of four very
highquality camera zoom ranges on the
back of the iPhone 15 Pro Max for
$1,200 compared to basically
$5,300 with the pro camera setup that
still lacks two of those cameras is just
insane now before I get into number
three I want to show you guys the New
Classic case aluminum from our sponsor
band workor the most premium case I've
ever seen because it's made out of a
precisely mil aluminum frame that you
quickly assemble for a perfect fit to
protect your iPhone while the back is
covered in durable quality leather made
in Germany with a soft lining and Max
safe support on the inside and you can
order one today by using the link in the
description with code maxtech 23 for a
free 1 o leather balm now getting into
reason number three we have portability
in order to bring the pro camera on our
trip to New York City we had to
sacrifice quite a lot of luggage space
to fit the camera as well as weight
because checked in bags have a limit of
50 lb and this setup is 3 lb because of
that it was an absolute pain to carry
around the city even with the strap
which I had to keep on my neck which
made me feel like a hunchback with all
of that constant weight and honestly
after the first few hours my next
started hurting so I decided to leave it
at the hotel and it ended up missing out
on a bunch of photo comparison
opportunities at Time Square so for the
remainder of the trip I kept swapping
with my wife who was able to fit the
strap around her shoulder to give me a
break since we were basically walking
around different parts of the city all
day for 3 days straight overall it was a
huge pain and I've decided that I will
never bring a pro camera to New York
again unless we have to make another one
of these videos now the iPhone on the
other hand is Tiny in comparison it
literally just fits in your pocket no
issues with luggage space or weight no
issues with neck strain or the annoyance
of having to carry it around everywhere
and swap it with my wife all the time so
I don't break my neck now for reason
number four I had to spend hours editing
all of the Raw photos that I took on
this Pro Camera to get them prepped for
the camera comparison before they were
actually looking good and comparable to
the iPhone that meant that I had to snap
the photos grab the SD card plug it into
the Mac then edit and Export them to
JPEG and if I wanted to share them on
social media I would then have to
airdrop them back to my iPhone this
reason alone is why so many professional
photographers who have expensive cameras
literally just use their iPhones you can
snap a photo and Bam you can share it on
Instagram instantly requiring no
additional editing or exporting to get a
great looking photo and if you want to
you can quickly add a filter or make a
quick adjustment and that's it so for
that reason the iPhone is so much better
and finally for reason number five the
iPhone simply has much better technology
in multiple different categories first
of all the area where the iPhone
performed the best was at night where
Apple night mode processing and photo
stacking allowed it to outperform the
Pro Camera basically every time because
with the Pro Camera I had to use noise
reduction which softened the details
while the iPhone was sharper at night
every single time the iPhone can also do
night mode portraits like this one while
blowing out less of the bright
background and having proper exposure on
my wife for a much better photo on top
of that the iPhone has insanely good
built-in stabilization including the new
action mode which allow owed me to run
around the cybertruck for this super
smooth footage which literally would not
be possible on the Pro Camera unless you
buy an expensive gimbal which are also
huge and would make it even harder to
carry around and fit into your luggage
plus the iPhone's new smart HDR 5 is
insanely good so much better than what
you can get on the pro camera so
throughout the comparison there were so
many pro camera photos that had the
details in the sky guy completely blown
out because the dynamic range just
doesn't match up compared to the iPhone
which can instantly stack multiple
exposures at once within a split second
to retain Shadow and Sky details and
finally the iPhone has the 120 mm 5x
camera which works incredibly well even
at night because of its gamechanging 3D
stabilization giving you an entire
entirely New Perspective that looks so
good so for all of those reasons the
iPhone 15 Pro Max is the first iPhone
ever that is finally better than a pro
camera and my final conclusion is that
it's no longer worth it to buy any pro
camera at all unless you're a
professional photographer or
videographer and you're making money
with it so hopefully you enjoy this
camera review and if you did you can
subscribe above and check out that full
15 Pro Max versus Pro camera video right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next
[Music]
one